good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight the United States says every
fourth grader learns is a meritocracy
what does that mean well it means that
our leaders do not inherit their
position as they do and say Brunei or
Saudi Arabia our leaders are selected on
the basis of merit their talents and
abilities are identified usually in
school and then up they go from there
that's why only the smartest kids were
told get into Yale undeniably
incandescent minds like Cory Booker and
Chris Cuomo and the kids of other
Democratic officeholders nerds they call
themselves with false modesty the
ordinary among us meanwhile go to
Rutgers in this country the hard truth
is and get used to it pal is that the
most impressive naturally rise to the
top that's what they tell us you still
believe that or are you starting to
suspect that the whole meritocracy
speech might just be an elaborate
justification for keeping mediocre
people in charge hmm before you make up
your mind on that question consider
Russia it's not the nation of Russia
that hasn't changed in a while Russia is
still in cold and vodka-soaked and only
marginally relevant place at least from
the perspective of the United States No
consider instead how a ruling class
views Russia to them Russia is the
single most important country in the
world nothing else comes close
just yesterday I Meet the Press over on
MSNBC excuse me Chuck Todd by the way is
a poster child for the modern
meritocracy and therefore by definition
a genius unlike you stop to sitting US
Senator in his tracks and all but
accused him of spying for Russia watch
this exchange in December of 2018 a
Ukrainian Court ruled that Ukrainian
officials had violated Ukrainian law by
by meddling in our election and that was
reported in New York Times according to
the New York Times a couple weeks ago US
senators were briefed after Fiona Hills
testimony that that actually this entire
effort to frame Ukraine for the Russian
meddling of 2016 of which you you just
made this case that they've done it that
actually this is an
furtive russia propaganda that this is a
russian intelligence
propaganda campaign in order to get
people like you to say these things
about ukraine's are you at all concerned
you're doing russian intelligence work
here are you at all concerned that
well gee Chuck now that you put it that
way it's pretty funny but what's funnier
what's weirder certainly is that we're
still talking about Russia at all we now
know it's not really a story it never
happened there was no collusion Russia
didn't hack our democracy the whole
thing was a talking point a ludicrous
talking point invented by the Hillary
Clinton campaign on or about November
9th 2016 to explain their unexpected
defeat in the last presidential election
we lost and we shouldn't have lost from
the start that has been the only
argument that underpins the Russia
conspiracy theory and now thanks to a
multi-million dollar investigation that
extended over a period of years that the
rest of us had to endure to the
exclusion of everything else that
conspiracy theory has died it was killed
in fact by robert muller and yet somehow
it lives on in the sneering accusations
of our mindless public intellectuals and
hair hats in the television anchor seat
you think that people like that would be
contrite maybe a little humbled after
the Moller report came out and proved
two years of hyperventilation wrong but
no they're more obsessed with russia
than they have ever been
watch poor mouth breathing chuck todd go
full joe mccarthy yesterday the fact
that russia was so aggressive does not
exclude the fact that president
poroshenko yeah actively worked for
secretary clinton now if i'm wrong it
was secretary i mean my goodness wait a
minute senator kennedy you now have the
president of ukraine saying he actively
worked for the Democratic nominee for
president I mean now come on I mean I
got to put up you realize the only other
person selling this argument outside the
United States is this man Vladimir Putin
Vladimir Putin are you now or have you
ever been a pawn of Vladimir Putin you
think they'd have more self-awareness
and to say things like that out loud
given American
treatment of course they never do not
only are these people unwise and
hysterical totally political utterly
dishonest they're also kind of dumb and
because shifting mental gears is hard
for dumb people it turns out the entire
on-air staff over at MSNBC is still
pretending that Russia collusion is the
most important story there is it's like
robert muller never delivered his report
is it possible that donald trump now
takes his beliefs in the world from the
president of russia he's acting as a
Russian asset he's amplifying talking
points put together by the Kremlin I
can't come up with a plausible
explanation for all of these elected
officials seeming to want to just turn
our government over to Vladimir Putin
this time the enemy is Russia which
seems to have consumed one of America's
great political parties whole the
Constitution is a piece of paper that
they would rather rip up or cut into
segments rather than defend this country
at all costs
the Russians set this whole thing up
we've left the good guys and have joined
the bad guys in the world and
Republicans writ large seem to be okay
with it now we are left with as I've
said before a transnational crime
syndicate massed as a government led by
a Kremlin asset Donald Trump believes
the words believes it in his heart the
words of a communist ex communist
dictator KGB officer rather than any
person in America
we're in danger we are in danger says
Malcolm Nance this is really
irresponsible and keep in mind then
everything we just played you erred in
the past two weeks
if you excluded debunk conspiracy
theories could any of these people
actually tell you why flat amir putin is
so bad why is he so bad bad Chuck Todd
says okay speak slowly so I can
understand what makes Vladimir Putin
worse then I don't know a whole long
list of American allies let's try the
king of Saudi Arabia for example for the
people who run the Emirates the people
on whose payrolls so many in Washington
are right now why is he worse than them
they couldn't answer that
for Chuck Todd and the rest of the
dummies Vladimir Putin isn't a real
person with actual ideas and priorities
in a country and beliefs no he stopped
being that long ago
he's a metaphor a living metaphor he's
the boogeyman step out of line and
you're a traitor in league with Vladimir
Putin let's put his picture on the
screen can we get his picture on the
screen yeah please the irony of course
is that Putin for all those faults does
not hate America as much as many of
these people do they really dislike our
country and they call other people
traitors because they're mouthing the
talking points of Putin these are people
who don't know anything about Russia
don't speak Russian who couldn't
identify three cities in Russia the rest
of the world isn't quite that dumb dumb
as it may be not quite that dumb the
French president Emmanuel macron for
example in the past month micron is
called NATO quote brain-dead because
NATO exists to provide the common
defense and yet it has with the fall of
the Soviet Union in 1991 no clear enemy
Europe and the United States micron has
said should have closer relationships
with Russia not more hostile ones so
does that make micron a stooge of Putin
is he a puppet of Moscow or could he
just be a rational leader the kind of we
don't have looking out for his country's
interests Russia is not America's main
enemy obviously no sane person thinks it
is our main enemy of course is China and
the United States ought to be in a
relationship with Russia aligned against
China to the extent that we can China is
the country that's currently right now
murdering tens of thousands of Americans
every year with fentanyl it's deep
populating parts of the country it's
pushing our life expectancy down
that's how profound a threat this is is
coming from China and our elites barely
care they don't even acknowledge it in
fact many of our politicians run
interference for the communist
government of China instead in
California politicians boycott other US
states for their moral transgressions
and then fly to China to praise this
dictatorship Michael Bloomberg doesn't
even do that he denies that China is a
dictatorship at all watch this China is
doing a lot
yes they're still building a bunch of
qualified power plants yes they are but
they are now moving plants away from the
cities there that the the Communist
Party wants to stay in power in China
and they listen to the public when the
public says I can't breathe the air
shaping is not a dictator he has to
satisfy his constituents oh he's not
going to survive it he's not a dictator
no he has to he is a constituency to add
to answer to
speaking of Stooges she's a pig is not a
dictator no he couldn't be voted at us
are there no elections the dictator is
not a dictator
that's prima facie disqualify and yet no
one's even noticed Bloomberg's comments
have gotten not 1% of the reaction than
anything Russia related gets the press
isn't racing to call Bloomberg a traitor
so that tape makes you wonder why cuz
most of Washington is already in the
tank for China during the days of the
Chinese emperors the imperial government
was supported by thousands of eunuchs
the Emperor's are gone but the eunuchs
clearly remain in case you haven't
noticed